in the video on sp3 hybridized orbitals
we went in pretty good detail about how
a methane molecule looks but just a bit
of review it's a tetrahedral shape you
have a carbon in the middle and then you
would have a hydrogen you could imagine
i'm drawing it like this because this
hydrogen is poking out of the page then
maybe you have another hydrogen that's
in the page
you have one above the carbon and then
you have one that's behind the page so
you can imagine it's like a it's like a
tripod
it's like a tripod with a pole sticking
out of the top of the tripod or if you
were to imagine the shape another way if
you were to connect the hydrogens if you
were to connect the hydrogens you would
have a four-sided pyramid
with a triangle is each of the sides so
it would look something like this it
would look
it would look something like
trying my best to draw
the pyramid would look something like
this if you could see through it so this
would be
one side
another side would be
over here
and then the back side would be over
here
and then the fourth side is actually the
side that's transparent out front so the
fourth side
the fourth side would be the actual
kind of thing that we're looking through
when we look at this pyramid it would be
this front side
right over here so you could imagine
different different ways this was the
case with methane
this is the case with methane now let's
extend this into a slightly more complex
molecule and that's ethane so the way
we've been drawing it so far i guess the
simplest way to draw ethane is just like
that by implication this is ethane
by implication you have a carbon there
and a carbon there
and they'll each have three hydrogens
bonded to it and we've drawn it
something like this
three hydrogens
bonded to each of these guys
but now we know that carbon has these
sp3 hybridized orbitals that likes to
form more of a tetrahedral shape when it
bonds so an ethane molecule would
actually look more like this let me draw
the carbons so i'll do the carbons in
orange so if that's the carbon and
that's the carbon so you can imagine you
have a carbon molecule here i'll draw it
as this little circle
and then if we have some perspective so
the carbon-carbon bond is going to look
like that and then you have another
carbon molecule
right over there so that's that bond
over here and we want both the carbons
all of their bonds to be kind of in a
tetrahedral shape
so then you can imagine this bond over
here
going like this
this bond going like that and you have
your hydrogen at the end
let's make the green
circles the hydrogens so you have that
hydrogen and then
or actually just the the circles we'll
call them hydrogen and you can imagine
this one maybe it's
coming out of the page a little bit that
is that hydrogen
that is that hydrogen let me label the
hydrogens actually
i'm doing it all in different colors so
you can see what i'm talking about and
then this hydrogen is going right below
it maybe pointed back a little bit so
that hydrogen is right over there so you
can see this carbon it has a its bonds
have a tetrahedral shape or if you just
looked at this part of it these would be
the base of the tripod and this would be
the thing sticking up now for this
carbon it'd be a very similar idea
a very similar idea this hydrogen right
here
this hydrogen right here might be
sticking down like this
and then
and i'll stop switching colors soon
enough it takes a lot of time that
hydrogen over there it's pointing out in
that direction
like that and then you would have let's
see what colors do i have left well i'll
just do yellow that hydrogen right there
maybe it's pointing out like that
so this is a possible
configuration for ethane and the way
that i've drawn this right now and you
can actually have a model that has this
where you have little you know wooden
sticks with balls in this that walls to
represent the actual atoms this is
called a balance a ball and stick model
ball
and
stick
model and this is a ball and stick model
for ethy now simpler way we could have
drawn this and this is called a
horseshoe projection or actually a
sawhorse production i always say
horseshoe a sawhorse projection it would
look like this this exact same
configuration of ethane in a sawhorse
projection and you know what a saw horse
looks like i saw well
it looks like what i'm about to draw
it looks like this
so you could well i could i could draw
it exactly the way i drew it here so you
have the carbon
carbon and then you have the
hydrogen hydrogen
hydrogen and then you have a
the way i've drawn it well the way i've
drawn it up here is more like this
just so we see the parallel and then we
can rotate things around the way i drew
it up here you have a
hydrogen
and hydrogen and then over here you have
a hydrogen hydrogen and hydrogen this is
a sawhorse
saw horse
projection
now
either way you depict it i mean these
are really the same way this is kind of
just like the laser way of doing it on
some level you're not drawing all of
these circles and all of that and you're
putting a little less care into actually
showing the angle how things are angled
away from the carbon and showing the
tetrahedral shape but in either case
when you start visualizing the molecule
in this way you start to realize there's
there's well there's actually an
infinite ways that these things can be
configured and that all comes from that
all comes from the notion that this is
just a sigma bond right here we learned
that in the video on sp3 hybridization
and sigma and pi bonds this is just a
sigma bond
sigma bond and so we can rotate around
the bonds one of these carbons could
rotate around the kind of the axis of
that bond without the other carbon
having to necessarily rotate with it if
this was a double bond if this was a pi
bond they would have to rotate together
so you could have a situation like i've
drawn here or you could have a situation
where they're kind of rotated the
inverse of each other and this is what i
mean so i'll do a ball and stick so
let's say this is our front carbon that
is our back carbon and we'll compare it
to this one over here
so let me draw this guy the exact same
way so he's got a hydrogen down here
he's got a hydrogen down there
he's got a
hydrogen up there and then he's got a
hydrogen up here
and he's got a hydrogen up here so that
part of the ethane looks identical now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
flip the other side of the ethane i
don't want you to pay close attention
because hopefully you'll see the
difference between the two so instead of
doing this blue ethane down here i'm
going to do the this blue hydrogen down
here i'm going to do it on top so this
blue one
i want to do that in blue
this blue hydrogen
put it on top so i'm just rotating this
around so if the blue hydrogen's on top
the so if i've rotated it so the blue
one's on top now and now the green one
the green one is going to go over
here
so now the green hydrogen is now
over here and then this
purple or this magenta hydrogen the way
i've rotated is now going to go over
here is now going to go over there
so what's the difference between this
configuration and this configuration
right here and we could have had every
other configuration in between but
what's the real difference here well
here the hydrogens are all you can
imagine that hydrogen is kind of if you
were if you were looking from that
direction that hydrogen is directly
behind that hydrogen that hydrogen is
directly behind that hydrogen that
hydrogen is directly behind that this is
called an eclipsed configuration or an
eclipsed conformation
so eclipsed
eclipsed
conformation con for
nation and this right here nothing is
behind anything if you went straight
back from this guy you'd get to this
point and no one's behind it and if you
went straight forward from this guy
you'll get so
in no way are
any of the guys in the back if once
again if you're viewing from this
direction are they blocked by any of the
people here so we call this a staggered
confirmation
staggered
confirmation now why do we even care you
know okay i can twist around this black
this this this this back molecule what's
that even going to do for our actual um
uh you know why does it even matter well
one it's you know it's just interesting
that you can actually change that this
thing can twist around without changing
the front uh without the front molecule
having to twist with it but even more
important these have different energy
levels so you can kind of think think of
them as
you're kind of twisting a spring and the
spring might want to go back to one
confirmation or another and to visualize
it a little better i'll draw what's
called a newman projection
a newman projection so i'm going to draw
this exact thing but with a newman
projection you draw the carbon molecules
directly in front or directly behind
each other so that so in this situation
you would draw the carbon molecule in
front would just be the intersection of
these bonds
so for the new for newman projection let
me draw that out
so it's a newman
newman
projection
and i'll start with the newman
projection for the staggered
conformation
so in the front we'll consider this
carbon the front carbon
we have our hydrogen pointing straight
down
down like that and we have a hydrogen
coming out
to the top left like that and then we
have this hydrogen over here coming up
to the right
i want to do that in that same color
so the front carbon is implicitly in the
intersection of the of the bonds of
these three hydrogen and then the back
carbon
the back carbon i said the front carbon
is the intersection of the bonds of
these three hydrogens the back carbon
you represent it as a circle
so this circle represents the back
carbon the front carbon is kind of that
point there this is a way of visualizing
it but if we were to draw it this way
the back carbon now has that blue
hydrogen popping off of it so it has
that blue hydrogen so it would look like
so it has that blue hydrogen this green
hydrogen
that green hydrogen
and then this magenta hydrogen
and then you have this magenta hydrogen
and when you look at it like this it is
more clear that it's staggered we're
just looking straight on to this ethane
molecule we look straight on the front
carbon they're obviously blocking each
other but this way you can see the front
carbon's hydrogens are staggered
relative to the back one so this is
right here once again this is staggered
now let's draw the eclipsed conformation
as a newman projection so as a newman
projection the front is going to look
the same you have
you have a hydrogen
there you have this hydrogen
you have that hydrogen and then you have
that blue or i guess that purple
hydrogen down here so that's the front
of it but the back the right behind it
so let me draw the back carbon remember
the front carbon is kind of represented
by just that dot the back carbon
the back carbon will represent like that
now the staggered conformation if
this guy's really behind that you're
gonna have to draw it like
like right there like right behind it
but since that's a little bit messy
normally when people draw a staggered
projection a staggered uh a an eclipsed
confirmation as in human projection
instead of directly eclipsing that last
that back hydrogen they'll put it to the
right a little or they'll stack they'll
push it off a little bit so that's that
hydrogen that magenta hydrogen is right
there it's really right behind the front
one but they're just this is just so you
can actually see it that it's there and
then finally you have this blue one down
there so that blue one is going to be
right
right over here so this is the eclipsed
this is the
eclipsed conformation as a newman
projection eclipsed confirmation
confirmation
and as you can see it's eclipsed the
back hydrogens are eclipsed by the front
ones if i were to draw it perfectly they
would be right behind it now there's one
other piece of i guess
one more idea i want to introduce you to
and that's the notion of the angle
between the different hydrogen so if you
wanted to say well what is this angle
what is this angle between the blue
hydrogen and this pink hydrogen right
here now you know when you actually
think of it in three dimensions it's
like well you know you can't really say
the angle over here between the blue and
the pink but when you on a newman
projection when you're just saying how
much are they rotated away from each
other this angle right here is called a
dihedral angle
dihedral
dihedral angle sometimes it just says
you know this this hydrogen relative
that hydrogen has a d a of in this case
60 degrees in this case this hydrogen
relative that hydrogen has a dihedral
angle of zero degrees and it's a way of
saying how staggered or how eclipsed you
are now one last thing i touched on the
idea is again why do we even care
well all of these hydrogens have
electron clouds around them and all of
these bonds have electron clouds around
them and electron clouds they're all
negative so they want to get as far away
from each other as possible they're all
stable now because they've bonded in
ways that they they have you know nice
stable structures everyone feels like
they have full
valence shells full orbitals
and so the the electron crowds want to
get away from each other now in this
situation in the eclipsed conformation
in this in the eclipse conformation this
hydrogen and this hydrogen let me do it
in let me do
this hydrogen and this hydrogen are are
as
are closer to each other than when you
go to the staggered conformation the
staggered conformation the closest
hydrogen to this guy is going to be
either that hydrogen or that hydrogen
but they're both further away than this
hydrogen was in the eclipse conformation
so in general the staggered conformation
is going to be more stable it's going to
have a lower potential energy you can
imagine that if you start with an
eclipsed confirmation
these guys are all going to get get away
from each other so it's kind of like
this is the wound
this is the wound conformation it has
higher potential energy so it'll want to
unwind and it'll want to unwind to a
staggered conformation because in this
conformation all the hydrogens have
gotten as far away from each other as
they can get